[Musique]
un bon soir jeudi 25 mars bienvenue dans
le journal préparé par la rédaction de
tv 60,18 voici les titres de cette
édition
presque une semaine désormais que les
yvelines sont en confinement les
commerces non alimentaires sont fermées
sauf que quelques échecs exception parmi
elles et c'est une nouveauté est les
boutiques culturel librairie de
proximité grandes enseignes restent
ouvertes
reportage aux clayes sous bois et à ils
encourent à partir de demain vendredi et
jusqu'à dimanche c'est le sidaction 2021
d'événements de mobilisation contre le
sida
cent soixante treize mille personnes
vivent avec le vih en france pourtant la
lutte est mise à mal avec la crise
sanitaire du coc vite 19 on en parle
avec notre invité jérôme andré directeur
de l'association trappistes hf
prévention et puis cela fait plus d'une
semaine que des étudiants
d'agroparistech bloquent l'entrée du
site de thiverval grignon il s'oppose au
processus de vente du domaine de 310
hectares qui appartient à l'état et les
manifestants craignent l'implantation
sur place d'un projet immobilier avant
de développer ses titres les enseignants
demandent plus de sévérité face au co
vide 19 et dans un communiqué paru
aujourd'hui le snuipp fsu des académies
de paris créteil et versailles syndicat
du premier degré appellent à la grève il
dénonce à un protocole sanitaire
impossible à tenir dans les
établissements et des conditions de
travail dégradées une organisation des
plus de plus en plus chaotique
oui les écoles doivent demeurer des
lieux d'enseignement et d'émancipation
des élèves mais cela ne peut pas nous
amener à accepter des risques
inconsidérés avance le communiqué l
ouverture des écoles quoi qu'il en coûte
n'est plus possible dit le syndicat qui
demande la fermeture systématique des
écoles touchées de manière importante
par le virus ou d'une classe dès le
premier cas décelé une demande dans un
contexte d'augmentation de l'épidémie au
sein des écoles selon nos confrères de
france info plus de 4000 cas positifs
ont été remontés lundi au ministère de
l'éducation nationale à la fermeture des
écoles est un dernier recours a dit le
gouvernement par la voix de son porte
parole gabriela talent ce matin de son
côté la présidente de la région ile de
france valérie pécresse a proposé
d'avancer les vacances de pâques de
quinze jours elles doivent débuter pour
la zone c le
17 avril c'est en raison d'une situation
très tendue en ile-de-france sur le
coronavirus qu'un nouveau confinement a
débuté samedi dernier pour quatre
semaines minimum
chose nouvelle par rapport aux deux
précédents les commerces culturels sont
autorisées à rester ouvert avec quelques
changements d'habitudes de la clientèle
pour les librairies de proximité et les
grandes enseignes le reportage de
bixente mais rien senti steban comme ça
on voit les gens des scouts sommes plus
près on passe maintenant en ligne sa
part est désormais considéré comme
commerce est essentiel les boutiques
culturelles peuvent rester ouverte
pendant le confinement un refuge pour
les clients pour la notion de culture
c'est vrai que ma part ces temps de
confinement peuvent a envie de se
retrouver s'évader justement par la
lecture pour avoir une sensation de
bien-être
les clients sont là on est content parce
qu'effectivement on avait un petit peu
peur mais ils sont là après il
transforme un petit peu leurs habitudes
d'achat parce que du coup ils passent
beaucoup plus part de la réservation a
pour limites et effectivement le temps
qu'ils peuvent passer en magasin pas de
peinture pas de produits dérivés pas de
déco dans les grandes enseignes jeu
vidéo 10-15 librairies sont épargnés
on vend beaucoup de liseuses et c'est
vrai que c'est bien parce que ça ne
remplace pas le livre papier c'est
vraiment un complément c'est une manière
différente de lire donc voilà ça c'est
plutôt chouette aussi et ça prouve qu'il
ya aussi beaucoup de gens qui se sont
remis à la lecture pendant le premier
confinement ça c'est plutôt bon signe
pour la culture les libraires constate
également un changement de fréquentation
dans leur aller avec un public parfois
plus jeunes on voit en effet des jeunes
des collégiens et lycéens qui viennent
faire des achats et le week-end c'est
beaucoup plus fort
c'est vraiment une catégorie de gens qui
fréquentent très bien la librairie nous
sommes très heureux que ça avec le
dernier point de chute qui reste c'est
c'est la librairie
voilà à quoi donc des chances réfugie là
dans le bon sens du terme
voilà un soulagement pour le secteur du
livre qui avait déjà limité les dégâts
en 2020 avec un recul de seulement 3,3
pour cent de son chiffre d'affaires la
campagne de vaccination va connaître un
nouveau tournant en france prévue pour
samedi et les injections pour les plus
de 70 ans pourront débuter finalement
dès demain vendredi a indiqué le porte
parole du gouvernement gabriel ata le
public éligible s'élargit donc après les
plus de 75 ans et les plus de 65 ans
avec comorbidités elle les créneaux de
vaccination sont ouverts depuis
aujourd'hui pour prendre des rendez vous
c'est sur la plateforme d'octo libre un
numéro vert national existe également
par téléphone le 0 800 00 910 je vous
disais dans les titres le sidaction est
organisé ces 26 27 et 28 mars avant
d'accueillir notre invité sur le sujet
et j'accueille en plateau amical et demi
d'euro bonds soir dans ça de la
rédaction de tv 78 pour parler de ce
rendez-vous déjà pouvez vous nous
rappeler le principe du sidaction
alors le sidaction a été créée en 1994
il désigne à la fois une association de
lutte contre le vih est un événement
l'association a pour but de collecter à
des fonds pour leur distribuer à des
associations qui font de la prévention
de l'accompagnement
il est de des structures en france mais
également à l'étranger en afrique ou
dans les pays d'europe de l'est
l'objectif du sidaction est également de
collecter des fonds pour aider à la
recherche c'est d'ailleurs la seule
association qui finance la recherche en
france et ce n'est pas le moment de
freiner ses investissements comme
l'expliquent 100 m fournier directrice
du pôle financement recherche et
associations du sidaction
il faut avoir confiance et un coq
aujourd'hui c'est encore dans le monde 1
million 800 mille nouvelles infections
chaque année en france c'est encore au
même niveau depuis un grand nombre
d'années c'est tous les ans encore aux
alentours de 6200
diagnostic qui sont réalisés en france
on est loin loin loin d'avoir d'être
venu à bout du vih
il faut absolument continuer en fait à
la fois à soutenir les associations qui
elle s'occupe et de prévention et
d'accompagnement des personnes vivant
avec le vih mais aussi de soutenir la
recherche c'est absolument indispensable
l'épidémie de cofidis va-t-elle
perturber la lutte contre le sida et
justement les actions de ces derniers
mois du sidaction à la situation n'est
pas habituel effectivement c'est peu de
le dire sur le terrain le clac au vide a
beaucoup de vers c'est le sidaction
depuis l'année dernière il ya eu 10 % le
dépistage en moins en 2020 et le chiffre
de 6200 nouvelles infections en france
devraient augmenter en cette année 2011
21 la recherche également été ralentie
la plupart des chercheurs se sont
mobilisés sur la cobi 19 ces derniers
mois et ont eu eux moins de temps pour
travailler sur les recherches qui
concernerait sur le vih
enfin au niveau de la structure il n'y a
pas eu de sidaction l'année dernière un
événement qui permet pourtant de
récolter un tiers des dons l'association
n'a collecté que 1.5 millions d'euros en
2020 contre près de 4,5 millions d'euros
ces dernières années cette année sera
donc crucial on écoute sandrine fournit
le vih libye ne s'arrête pas et
aujourd'hui on a pu si vous voulez en
2020 en puisant tout simplement dans nos
fonds propres
maintenir des niveaux de financement
pour la recherche pour les associations
à même hauteur que l'année précédente
on ne pourra pas le faire une année
supplémentaire donc là aujourd'hui plus
que jamais on a besoin vraiment de mener
cette opération du sidaction est du
reste je pense que de nos donateurs les
plus fidèles et plus régulier le
comprennent très bien
enfin chiffres locales pour refermer
cette chronique dans les yvelines
l'impact du vih et 219 personnes
infectées pour 1,1 million d'habitants à
paris ce chiffre et 2 420 personnes
infectées par million d'habitants pour
donner au sidaction ce week-end vous
pouvez le faire par sms au 92 110 ou sur
leur site internet
merci michael pour toutes ces précisions
et on parle également de ce sujet de la
lutte contre le sida avec jérôme andré
bonsoir bonsoir le directeur da chef
prévention santé l'association installée
à trappes intervient dans l'innovation
en prévention santé aussi pour le
dépistage notamment sur le vih en
décembre dernier
vous étiez intervenus dans notre
émission sept huit sociétés j'invite
d'ailleurs les téléspectateurs à revoir
l'émission sur notre site internet tv 78
points comme et vous ne faisiez part à
l'époque de votre inquiétude notamment
sur la baisse des dépistages qui est
intervenu en 2020 est ce que vous êtes
toujours inquiet aujourd'hui est ce que
finalement le kobe de 19 a totalement
éclipsé cette lutte contre le sida alors
malheureusement le commis 19 avec ses
beaucoup de prévention donc en france et
notammment effectivement sur la lutte
contre le sida
nous on annonce effectivement en ile de
france au moins 60% de dépistage en
moins pour une raison qui est assez
simple c'est que effectivement donc il y
a eu le premier confinement le second
les gens sont allés beaucoup moins au
dépistage que ce qui était initialement
prévu
et puis il ya une autre problématique
c'est que les actions d'aller vers c'est
à dire le fait ce qu'on fait nous achète
prévention c'est d'aller dans les
universités les centres commerciaux et
les choeurs de cité vous imaginez bien
qu'on ne pouvait pas donc créé deux
clusters les facs étaient fermées donc
on a effectivement énormément de
dépistage qui ne se sont pas faits en
ile-de-france et puis le dernier
phénomène qui se passe c'est que les
centres de dépistage sont aussi
réquisitionnée pour la vaccination au
vide
donc c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle un
d'ailleurs pour la vaccination que vides
mais du coup ça a un réel impact sur
donc les autres problématiques et
notamment la lutte contre le vih 1 vih
qui est toujours présent avec 173 milles
personnes qui vivent avec le vih en
france 38 millions de personnes au
travers du monde et chaque année en
france on estime qu entre 6000 et 7000
personnes et découvrent leur
séropositivité
du coup le risque avec la baisse de ces
dépistages c'est que moins de personnes
découvrent justement leur séropositivité
exactement donc on a une vraie
problématique c'est que 60% de dépistage
en moins veut aussi dire que quelque
part il va y avoir 60 % des gens qui
auraient dû être dépisté positif qui ne
le seront pas et qui du coup contamine
encore donc d'autres personnes donc on
s'attend à une explosion des chiffres
sur les infections sexuellement
transmissibles mais aussi sur les
chiffres de contamination donc dus au
vih
à cause de cela puisqu'aujourd'hui on
l'a
jamais assez est quelqu'un qui est
séropositif mais diagnostic et va
pouvoir avoir accès à un traitement et
quand on a accès à un traitement et bien
on peut devenir donc en charge virale
indétectable et ne plus être
contaminants donc ce sont des gens qui
n'auront pas été dépisté qui n'auront
pas été diagnostiquée qui ne rompt pas
été mis dans la boucle de soins et qui
deux fêtes vont continuer à contaminer
d'autres jour elle vous le disiez tout à
l'heure h f prévention oeuvre notamment
auprès du jeune public des étudiants
à ce sujet il ya un dernier sondage ifop
qui est paru pour le sidaction qui est
assez inquiétant et qui montrent une
dégradation continue des connaissances
sur le sida 33 % des jeunes estime qu'
ils sont mal informés sur sur le sujet
24% même des 15-24 ans qui ont été
interrogés pensent que le virus du sida
peut se transmettre en embrassant une
personne séropositive c'est des données
qui sont en augmentation par rapport aux
dernières études qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire ce que souvent vous venez ici en
plateau pour déconstruire ses idées
reçues elles l ont toujours la dent dure
à ses idées reçues alors elles ont
toujours la dent dure et puis je dirais
que malheureusement une épidémie peut en
cacher une autre
et pour le coup c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle pour la lutte contre le sida
parce que outre le retard au dépistage
il y à aussi donc effectivement moins
d'argent du fait du sidaction qui est
donc eu moins présent enfin qui était
pas du tout présent l'année dernière et
qui a difficilement donc cette année on
espère qu'il va y avoir plus de dons en
revanche il ya aussi un problème sur la
recherche puisque on peut estimer que la
recherche donc pour trouver donc des
solutions efficaces à savoir la
recherche du vaccin contre le virus du
vih va prendre probablement dix ans pour
une année de non financement et de
retard donc on risque de prendre dix ans
supplémentaires pour ne pas avoir
effectivement donc mis les moyens qu'il
fallait dans la lutte contre le sida
donc c'est plutôt catastrophique je suis
désolé de ne pas donner de bonnes
nouvelles
et puis une autre idée qu'on peut
déconstruire c'est que même si
effectivement il y a aujourd'hui un
vaccin sur le qui-vive 19 et bien
effectivement le virus et date n'est pas
du tout la même chose souvent on entend
parler des gens qui disent ah bah
comment ils ont fait
pour trouver vite un vaccin sur le co
vide et pourquoi ils ne trouvent pas de
vaccin sur le vih le pays achète un
virus qui mute quasiment à chaque
personne
donc en réalité il y à une adaptabilité
du virus qui est très forte et qui pour
le coup fait qu' on n'est pas du tout
même si on entend virus
on n'est pas du tout dans la même chose
et donc ça fait partie des nouvelles
idées à déconstruire
merci germandrée d'avoir été avec nous
je rappelle directeurs d'achats
prévention toutes les informations sur
le site internet de l'association et je
vous rappelle que le sidaction se
déroule à partir de demain à vendredi et
c'est jusqu'à dimanche pour faire un don
elle les informations qui vont
s'afficher on peut faire un don par sms
est également sur le site du sidaction
www.dow.com sion point org
dans le reste de l'actualité cet
accident mortel à poissy un garçon de 12
ans est décédé hier mercredi il a été
percuté par un taxi alors qu'ils
circulaient à trottinette vers 11h45 au
croisement de la rue du temple et de la
rue de la libération est les secours
intervenus rapidement ne sont pas
parvenus à le réanimer l'enfant venait
de sortir de l'école et rentrer chez lui
d'après les premières informations de
nos confrères du parisien
l'automobiliste un homme d'une
quarantaine d'années ne roulait pas à
vive allure
plusieurs cellules psychologiques ont
été ouvertes et mise à disposition par
la ville et l'éducation nationale la
mobilisation des étudiants
d'agroparistech à thiverval grignon
depuis et dix jours ils protestent
contre la vente de leurs établissements
ces étudiants veulent d'un projet
écologique plutôt qu'immobilier sur cet
espace qui va déménager l'école va
déménager sur le plateau de saclay très
prochainement le reportage à ce sujet de
patrick jacques de dixmude et l'honore
sinoquet et d'astrid bergère planning de
conférences et d'ateliers en tous genres
sit in et banderoles bien accroché les
étudiants de l'école agroparistech sont
organisés depuis le 15 mars
ils bloquent l'entrée de leur
établissement pour protester contre la
vente au travers d'un appel d'offres du
centre de grignon ou une partie de
l'école est installé depuis 1826 on veut
que ce site des rares est public tout
simplement parce que
ce site est chargé d'un patrimoine
matériel et immatériel et naturel qui
selon nous sont indispensables dans le
cadre des transitions futur ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose qu'on
demande c'est de pouvoir rediscuter du
coup les termes du cahier des charges de
la vente
cette vente fait suite au déménagement
voter en 2015 des étudiants de première
année sur le plateau de saclay pour
financer ce déménagement l'école devant
le centre historique de grings quatre
offres ont donc été déposés dont des
sociétés de construction et promoteurs
immobiliers ce qui ne plaît pas aux
étudiants le seul candidat qui a été
vraiment transparent il se trouve que
c'est justement ce projet-là de la
communauté de communes avec l'union 2026
qui sont venus nous expliquer leur
projet qu'ils sont a priori d'accord
pour nous inclure aussi dans la
construction de leur projet mais on n'a
aucune information sur les autres les
étudiants sont soutenus par une partie
des professeurs et chercheurs
d'agroparistech et de l'inra qui se
reconnaissent dans leur mobilisation
on peut pas continuer à faire comme si
nous n'existions pas pour cette vente
j'engage je rejoins complètement la la
la demande qu'ont fait les étudiants
récemment ils sont trouvés une des
modalités d'action pour le moment
totalement non violente et de façon
assez exceptionnelle je dois tenir ce
vendredi 26 mars est la date butoir pour
que l'état suspende annuler confirme
l'appel d'offres les étudiants demandent
la mise en pause pour rediscuter les
termes ils l'ont fait savoir à un
conseil du ministre julien de normandie
ancien élève d'agroparistech et ils le
feront à nouveau savoir en manifestant
ce vendredi à 14h de son côté la
direction n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer
mais la visite de valérie pécresse ali
mais ce mercredi la présidente de la
région ile de france et est à l' usine
de production dunlopillo spécialisée
dans la literie au programme discussions
avec la direction et les syndicats pour
faire le bilan du plan de relance de la
marque
placé en liquidation judiciaire début
2020 dunlopillo a été repris par le
groupe finadorm et a bénéficié en
novembre dernier et du plan relance
industries de la région à hauteur de 800
mille euros l'occasion aussi de rappeler
le plan de réindustrialisation
franciliens au micro de bixente mejia
senti steban on a aidé 160 entreprises
avec cette aide pm appendice rond est
d'ores et déjà on a
sauvé consolidé je dirais dix mille cinq
cents emplois
ça c'est ed et on en a créé trois mille
la désindustrialisation s'est terminée
pour réindustrialiser mais c'est de
l'industrie du futur c'est une industrie
plus écologiques les l'industrie
beaucoup plus numérique c'est une une
industrie qui investit pour pour être
compétitive tout en gardant ces emplois
là la région également va apporter une
aide d'un million d'euros à renault
flins pour créer sur place à un pôle de
recherche de recyclage automobile
à propos de transport justement la
fréquentation des métros trains et bus
est en légère baisse depuis quelques
jours dans la région
un recul de 12% selon ile-de-france
mobilité observé depuis le déclenchement
du confinement sur le territoire une
baisse toutefois moins importante que
lors du deuxième confinement où la
fréquentation était descendue à 40% de
son niveau habituel contre 45 %
aujourd'hui
jusqu'au 27 mars c'est la semaine de la
presse et des médias dans l'école tv 78
est partenaire de l'événement
à cette occasion nous avons rencontré
les élèves du collège marcel robbie à
saint-germain-en-laye qu'elle regarde
quel regard porte-t-il sur l'information
réponse dans ce reportage de nicolas
landry et de patrick jacques de dixmude
leur donner le goût de l'information de
la bonne information clarifier certifiés
et vérifier c'est avec cet objectif que
s'engage la discussion avec ses élèves
du collège marcel robbie de saint
germain en laye d'abord en découvrant la
manière dont ils suivent l'actualité
moi je m'informe avec mes parents à la
télé et grâce aux réseaux sociaux
parfois savoir se méfier ça peut être
déformé par mensongère parfois donc pour
savoir s'il faut savoir se méfier mais
général durant cette matinée 60 élèves
ont participé aux échanges
l'occasion pour eux aussi de découvrir
le fonctionnement de la caméra avec
patrick jacques de dixmude j ai ri de
télé 78 donc on voit d'abord le plan
latin en régie et là tu peux le dire mon
collègue vasile ça tourne
[Musique]
pour moi c'est une façon de s'informer
et je trouve ça hyper intéressant de
s'informer par rapport à la presse
et après c'est très important parce que
ça me permet de nous informer on a de la
chance d'être dans un pays dans laquelle
la presse est libre
je m'informe beaucoup parce que mes
parents lisent les journaux très
régulièrement et on en parle ensemble
participer à la semaine de la presse et
des médias dans l'école la volonté doré
lisier diot professeur de lettres
classiques
je sens que c'est toujours très
important de mettre en évidence ce qu'on
fait tous les jours au sein de la classe
avec le monde réel la vie comme elle est
surtout dans un monde dans lequel on est
aujourd'hui qui où l'information leur
tombe dessus sans prévenir parfois leur
apprendre à exercer un peu leur esprit
critique c'est très important pour moi
en tout cas dans mon métier ça donne du
sens en espérant que nous avons
contribué à leur manière de bien
s'informer et peut-être créer des
vocations
d'ailleurs demain vendredi l'émission
cette ut week-end sera justement
consacré à cette semaine de la presse
le sport avec ce gros coup réalisé par
le golfeur antoine ros nerfs le
pensionnaire du goal de la boulie à
versailles a parfaitement débuté ce
mercredi le championnat du monde de
match-play ya austin au texas il s'est
brillamment imposé face à l'un des
favoris du tournoi le numéro cinq
mondial l'américain bryson 2 chambaud 1
grâce à cette victoire l'yvelinois de 28
ans est donc en très bonne position pour
sortir de sa poule
prochaine rencontre et pas des moindres
face au britannique tommy fleetwood et
aussi face aux sud-coréens 6 ou kim
avant de refermer ce journal une idée de
sortie pour le week-end le domaine de
dampierre en yvelines rouvre ses portes
samedi après une pause hivernale il sera
accessible de 10 heures à 17 heures 30
du mardi au dimanche
ainsi qu'aux jours fériés et vous pouvez
vous rendre sur place bien sûr si le
domaine est situé dans un rayon de 10 km
autour de votre domicile l'ensemble des
jardins sera ouvert info et tarifs sur
le lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité très belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]